j'ai fait une saint-valentin de ouf j'ai
un seul chez moi en fait ouais et j'ai
un ami qui m'a parlé d'un site pour
trouver l'âme soeur en moins de 30
minutes avec les femmes les plus
ouvertes de ma région
attire les factures de 20 euros pour les
frais de fonctionnement du site
rencontré la fille et elle était très
pressée à la partie au bout d'une heure
pile et voilà mais j'espère que je la
revois non non c'est une belle soirée ça
va vous sinon
tu te serais arrêté à l'est les filets
plus ouverte de ma région c'est et
[ __ ] et derrière ça a tourné glow
basse et surtout ceux souvent son
problème un qui que vous avez fait qu'on
pourrait s'en aller il a fait quoi
patoche on a fait un petit dîner en
amoureux genre quoi la maison bah ouais
j'aurais la maison quoi sera convié m
même pas aller au restaurant après
l'émission bat et on finit à 21h03 les
ans qu'on sorte il est 22 heures c'est
mam est alors arrêté quoi les gars vous
avez fait quoi bas âge en rigolait vous
avez fait du bobino l'éboulis qui
bafoue gengembre quoi mais quelle race
rare et manger en jambes et après un
week end
c'est le
gingembre est affreux dimaga besoin de
ces moustiquaires un petit peu
benayoun tu nous donnes de capital
de cast iron merguez
alors eh bien ça oui non mais on a passé
une bonne soirée ça vous avez vous êtes
embrassé au moins sur la bouche bah je
t'embrasse tous les jours sur la bouche
bée abbas de galoches avec la langue
surseoir à thouars non mais
mais l'histoire d'israël sipa très soupe
de langues tout ça là c'est la whey away
non mais ça y est c'est fini ça bon avec
salman al ahmad le périnée
castaldi alors moi j'avais tout prévu
j'avais prévu un hôtel non pas bon mais
tout prévu finalement la carte n'est pas
passé
[Rires]
d'accord à rien c'est vrai j'avais tout
prévu et monfils à une otite dernier
donc du coup on achetait la mêlée est
j'ai des amis voilà j'ai perdu les arts
n'en résout les anneaux
me suis rangé que vous avez prévu
d'aller dans quel hôtel dit mme bah
celui où vous êtes allés ya pas
longtemps
jamais
fait quelque chose non franchement je
suis resté à la maison avec des potes ma
joue aux cartes on m'a commandé des
burgers rien de ou en toit
à double allons
[Applaudissements]
je
ne connais pas mais je vous regarde j'ai
l'image de boue un trader c'est très
sympa daniel comment ça se goupille et
vous ah bah moi j'ai une gratte et à la
porte de gilles toute la nuit mais n'a
pas ouvert
[Rires]
mcdaniels oui pardon excusez moi j'avais
cas combien de portières qui n'a pas
entendu ce que des bras celle-ci
l'émission hard on regarde la convainc
de partir non c'est là seulement salle
de gym j'avais et émoustillé par tout ce
qu'on avait dit fatou faye toujours pas
pour l'instant pas de banon visé parce
que vous êtes sur teen d'heure
maintenant offrir oui mais j'ai pas y'a
pas le petit il n'ya pas le petit croche
et zz top 200 messages sur instagram
ses 200 duels
après son passage sur instagram et du
même cas le gall n'hésitez pas le
changer la forme voyez ses coordonnées
et aux forces de police
demandez vous la caisse qui la peine
huit mois c'est très simple je suis
rentré hier j'ai plus de l'autoroute
direction n'a qu'un seul nom
la police saisit ce concept j'ai pris là
dessus s'est ouvert la porte
je suis rentré
partis déposer une voiture qui m'avait
prêté j'ai mon pote really qui m'avait
prêté
[Rires]
à la gare est pas la voiture qui martin
de ré gucci la voiture y'a pas toi
d'herblay l'étape haddad n'a pas d'armée
pour la voiture
quelle race race et la mairie allait
nous le zoo d'irriter alors ta leur île
arrivant à l'âge est là dit oui bon
aujourd'hui je suis très heureux je dis
pas pourquoi il ne dit pas parce qu'hier
j'ai pas plus à la saint valentin tout
seul je vais du coup ça te rend heureux
il a dit ouais parce que du coup j'ai
pas dépenser haroun pour une nana
vous allez croire cet
[Rires]
essai sur la diffamation c'est sur la
voiture alors question est ce que c'est
vrai je confirme qu'on peut être
choquer
mais c'est vrai qu'il a dit sarah dean
c'est vrai nom gérad il est pas là en
fait c'est vrai
mais c'est la méchanceté de ma gueule à
l'affectation